uh financially you're gonna have a big
edge
yeah yeah i know george you also had uh
one of the things that i
um actually use as reference for today's
questions here is uh
the episodes you did on will the housing
market crash or will it you know
continue on as to like
right now the housing market is at above
where it was in 2007
as far as yeah over inflation of it
right now and
you had and you do a whiteboard kind of
video and
uh one i think it was like the the
fourth one along the way
was uh you introduced the word hypergamy
to
um to your audience which i think was
sort of uh
something that was maybe it's fresh to
your audience but to us obviously
i mean gosh i'm not royal tomas is
synonymous with hypergamy right
um but um can you give us just a little
quick breakdown of that
because that's going to lead us into um
the marriage topic that i had here so
like what
what exactly were you talking about in
that that particular bullet point um
with respect to how family formation and
how marriage and how hypergamy sort of
affect
the the the housing market because like
as
like you know family single families
buying buying homes right now as opposed
to renting homes as opposed to even
forming families in the first place so
can you give us just like a really brief
rundown of what that was all about
yeah i mean it's not just the housing
markets it's the economy
more broadly they've got a saying in
economics that
demographics equal destiny
and so if you've got an environment
where
women are let's say doing better
economically
and we all know that women are going to
choose a long-term
boyfriend or husband based on hypergamy
meaning that they're going to date
sideways and up so if they're
climbing the socioeconomic ladder that
just means that there's going to be
fewer and fewer
men that are acceptable to them
and you know like rich says it's not
good it's not bad it just
it just is it is what it is so that
means that uh
you know pareto distribution if it was
uh
you know 20 of the guys getting 80 of
the women
uh a couple decades ago i think over the
next
this could happen quickly two three five
years that's going to go to about
you know 5 of the guys and there's going
to be a larger pool of women
that are seeking those individuals but
what that also means
is there's going to be a larger
percentage of males that are just
completely
out of the picture like they they
subconsciously they realize that they
have zero chance
of um of uh you know passing on their
dna
and i think you get evolutional that's
where you know a lot of the drive comes
from so you have a
a a setup where you've got fewer and
fewer kids
being produced being born so you have
you know fewer people which would have
the opposite effect
of the baby boomers you know we always
hear how that was a big
boom for the economy because you had
this huge glut of people coming into
their spending years and doing all these
things
and driving up asset prices and driving
at home prices and consuming
if you have an economy that's 70
consumption that's
a good thing for economic growth but now
if you've got fewer and fewer and fewer
children being born
you know that's a bad thing for now but
it's a really bad thing for
15 uh 20 years down the line
so that's but again my point there is
it's not just with housing
those demographic issues uh bleed
through the entire economy
now aaron uh you and i have discussed
the uh i think
and i actually put this in my fourth
book is the uh the article by
um morgan stanley the rise of the she
economy
yeah and um how are you from uh aaron
what were the numbers on that
do you remember i keep i keep going up
because i'm so i have
so many statistics and numbers in my
previous book they blur together
it was something like between 18
and 50 or 25 and 50. working age women
i'm working age women between right
whatever yeah you know
and roughly half or 45 percent were
going to be
single and childless or without children
so
by 2030 yeah by 2030. yeah so
don't quote me on those numbers but a
shockingly high percentage
of women in their working age years will
have never
married or had children and so
and and this is this is something that
you know a company like morgan stanley
is already predicting and using to
forecast
for investments for uh i mean they're
they're at least certain enough to put
out a very detailed after the fact i
think it's actually part of the blog now
um what you can do to sort of like plan
ahead and like i don't know invest in
cat food and box wine or whatever it is
you know
for the future now my question is so
first question is this is why do you
think
that is why do you think that that that
that demographic by
i mean within the next let's say nine
years is going to be
that significant at this stage and
you're asking me
yeah and as they were told because they
were told to
like i've been wrestled with a with a
human
theory like how susceptible are people
to brainwashing indoctrination
and i would say the vast majority are
completely susceptible to because i've
seen it i've just seen it
uh and for the longest time young
women girls starting at five lord knows
even now with pre-k
and and there's the book out called
feminist baby
uh the i know going back to 1980 when i
was just a little
little runt uh it was already there yes
we knew women didn't need us yes we knew
girls could do everything else
uh and that has not only maintained
itself
uh but it's been turned up to 15 20 25
exponentially
uh and i've witnessed that i've seen it
young women or maybe not so young women
anymore are responding to what they were
told to do
this is right this is what you should do
uh to a larger extent uh you don't need
a man
uh they may would like to have one but
they don't need one and that's
maybe they don't believe it but they act
on it and you could see this in their
actions and their behaviors they are
postponing marriage they're postponing
children
uh in in the research for for my book i
went through some polling data and where
young women and not so young women
prioritize things in their life
marriage and children depending on their
age was not in the top three
sometimes not in the top two if they got
a little bit older um
and this just kicks family formation
children
marriage uh down the road and what that
has been
replaced with men instead where
love and husband and children uh has
been career and self-actualization and i
would also say
uh politics to a large regard or some
kind of
i wouldn't call it a substitute for
religion not necessarily christianity or
islam or judaism or something like that
but
feminism environmentalism uh making
change
you know this um excellent existentially
yeah good
and a substitute for agency where it's
like okay your career is there but what
are you doing
on the side well i'm dog rescue would be
another perfect example uh
it kind of runs the gambit um but that's
that's why and they're doing what they
were told
uh very much like us young men we did
what we were nice guys
we you know we just we did what we were
told we're just the ones that seem to be
waking up right now
so that's that's why i think that's
happening
you